hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares this is a new DLC that was
just released recently called Cara Mari
Hospital much I don't know why it's
called that but I definitely liked the
idea there being more spirits but some
Java skiers because it's an interesting
adorable adventure into nothingness
hello keep your chin up oh hey every day
is Wednesday now I don't know what that
has to do with the guy by t I think
that's by tea from Bracken wood if I'm
not mistaken that looks exactly like by
tea from Bracken wood hello save me
please from 995
familias is our god and it always shakes
like that Oh God numbers going up Wow
those I don't even have a room number
anymore where am I going
tell me something tells me that spooky
may not have a hand in whoa and if you
haven't seen me play Spooky's House of
jump-scares playlist in the description
it's an amazing game
squeaky dinky hello I don't seem to be
in the normal layout of the house
anymore I mean after the ending of
Spooky's House of jump-scares which
admittedly the creator said that it was
not going to be a very serious I can't
go and it definitely was not that no are
we still in the randomly generated bull
I think we might be this is look happy
anybody home I can't even remember the
rooms down here okay I don't believe you
oh okay thank you any more instructions
would be nice I have nothing left
okay thanks for being nondescript about
your somehow hidden cellar rooms okay
whatever I seriously there's no more
room numbers Oh importing 3d models this
might take a while oh oh hey oh cool I
don't recall what game engine this is
actually made it so I don't know if this
game maker and stuff like that but
that's pretty cool I mean
hey okay it seemed a lot more sinister
than that
wash your hands cap lumpy uplift chin
your own spouse pay attention to the
chores work hard and and and bone bone
bone a moan daily I think that's what
it's it men women
oh no I immediately went left but okay
well bathrooms in horror games what's
good sign broken ball
Oh God something happened here probably
not a good thing okay
no key no secret e Dukey no nothing
there anything I could see in there
it doesn't look happy in there nothing
looks happy anywhere over here hello
anybody I need to find where I'm going
I'm hoping this someone seen some jump
scares okay
the woods never forget so whither should
you probably neither little confused as
to where I'm supposed to go and what I'm
supposed to do cuz I know this is called
Cara Mari hospital and when I first
approached this deal C I thought it was
Katamari Hospital joint pain be afraid a
cancer cancer being afraid that you have
no idea distance that's my best
interpretation ah
here we go dr. Hamada the patient has
displayed increased depression after
being informed of their terminal disease
i prescribed an antidepressant to
regulate this but was later told that i
had cancelled the prescription i have no
memory of canceling the meds nor can i
find any evidence that my orders were
tamponade still had been i really then I
still have my swing swung the axe
alright
joint pain stairs whoa this look not
cleaned for it being a hospital okay I
entered a bad domain I'm sorry you know
I said it wasn't clean yeah this is
probably what I was talking about over
here with all the crime crimes
oh boy oh boy oh boy
nurse Tanaka it seems we are losing
patients due to surgical complications
much more often than normal one of the
doctors been doing half of these
procedures seemed completely unnecessary
I know the doctors and surgeons are
above me and probably know many things I
don't but that's getting strange huh
yeah I'm I'm agreeing if I wasn't
totally afraid for my life right now
oh hello office keeping two okay so now
that I got the office key I imagine that
everything's going to go horribly
morning Andy man now hey God sign oh
it's balm ascorbic look at you
apparently I can't get fasten so I'm
just gonna leave it do it's weird always
make himself all right back up the
stairs thank you I'm gonna forget I ever
went to that part of the hospital I
wonder what kind of people get better
down there okay so I got the office key
oh hello your pain is just a product of
your broken mind okay thank you my
playing fan beau oh by the way Fran bow
is gonna be returning I just haven't had
a time to do it with with hour-long
episodes of tickets time don't bother
the doctors they've got enough blood on
their hands deal with it yourself deal
with what myself my own broken mind I
don't know how to deal with that
I barely know how to deal with being
alone in a hospital
aha okay now we're making progress
hello damn
a lot of wandering back at Oh Hillel it
seems the other me has been giving him
large doses of hallucinogenics they have
worsened the depression and he is now
constantly screaming and expressing
terror at seemingly random intervals
I've tried using a dialysis machine to
remove some of the drugs but it seems
futile why is there another you floating
around here and why do you seem so
nonchalant about it and who are you
sending these messages to Oh looks like
something fits inside that's an odd 20
knocking every random hole you see just
fine Oh God something bad happened to
that okay I mean it seems redundant to
say that something bad had obviously
something horrible in here anything
anything at all anything I was just
informed that the procedure to extract
the patient's liver became fatal I don't
know why why did we take his liver there
are no donation requests and he was
showing signs of improvement the
surgical staff told me I personally
demanded the liver be removed for an
emergency transplant and the worst thing
is I found it I found his liver his
entire liver just sitting on my desk
desk that is it seems a little odd I
mean I'm not gonna question it you're
the doctor obviously you know what's
best so okay so I found the key to the
maintenance room I blacked out today
while driving to work one minute I was
driving down the road and then an
instant I was standing outside my car
staring down at a dead cat I must have
hit it with my car and felt sorry the
image of the dead cats constantly
unnerved me today how did I manage to
hit it in such a way to make the body
completely twisted around like that I
don't know why did it get silent
damnit okay so I got a key to the
maintenance room and I'm pretty sure
that was downstair in the basement of
hell so let's meander that way right
quick right
chocolate chocolate Aguila oh why would
I turn that off
oh because of the electronically sealed
doors that's probably oh we got worse
down here I don't like that oh oh no oh
no oh that's bad oh that's me out oh
this is riad oh this is so bad oh god
why why have I done any of this Oh Kara
Mari Hospital I'm so sorry
Oh oh god oh god oh what's up is but I
don't want to know
oh god oh [ __ ] me oh god oh god oh [ __ ]
me oh god what was that
thank you security guard with large
bulbous hands not cool I'm not okay with
that
oh man oh god oh that scared the piss
out of me uh-huh
ah all right let's try it he was very
quick
that's for dick hi oh my god oh you're
so weird
Oh can I go down thank you oh my god
that was so scary
I don't even know why he's like now that
I'm looking at amis nothing Oh God okay
this bad probably being down here is not
the best option
can I save I need to go I should go back
up to the water fountain and save I
shouldn't be in the Mora this probably
fits in that hole that I was talking
about don't mean the bars okay this is
bad oh I should have saved and it's over
isolation room is salvation room I'm
going upstairs where I can save this I'm
not doing too grand at the MoMA
hey buddy how you doing buddy how's it
going buddy hey Bubba i'ma call you bub
the buddy Bubba buggy
hey oh hi that's bigger it's very
interesting
Oh keep going you crew and I'm sure
you'll make it out free thanks spooky
girl he's such a pleasure
all right oh okay
so now that I saved I'm gonna end this
episode here and I'm gonna continue this
very soon god damn my heart is not okay
with this game it's so misleading
because it just seems so innocent then
gets so terrifying so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think of the comments down
below
enjoying this game let me know and as
always else
in the next video